[Music]
competition
is a giant part of the twitch experience
it seems like every day there's an
esport event pulling in
huge numbers one day it's league with an
insane mechanical play
what's the casual one because
another day it's cs go with some pro
player fragging out of his mind in order
to clutch around
you're on brawler but xavier wants to
kill there's the head shot pulls the
back there and the opposite side who's
got the triple
but a few weeks ago twitch's biggest
competitive spectacle wasn't between
elite esports players fighting it out
over some
giant prize pool no it was between a
boomer
and a night owl with a consistently
inconsistent schedule
duking it out over a game overflowing
with nostalgia
moon moon clint stevens and tony hawk
pro skater is clanny to go this game
chat it's like i say that he was racing
me or whatever
i assume he lost we have beaten moon to
20 million i
told you guys
[Music]
like if you're my agent twitch chat you
shouldn't have to ask
what's currently happening because you
did it
because you've done you've been in this
exact spot
right here for the last half decade
clint stevens has been a pillar for the
twitch night shift
regularly streaming into the early hours
first came as ocarina of time 100
speed runs where he was crushed time and
time again
by dampi basically instead of getting
blessed
by the damn big gods we got a turd
okay twice then there's the super mario
64 speed runs that ended in hilarious
chokes
oh my god
oh dude that's not what you want to see
or there's the non-speed running streams
where he gets to bond with his chat more
while playing random games
dig right four diamonds
oh my god whatev
is there exactly four here oh my god i
got exactly
four how did he know how the [ __ ]
did he know clint's streams have become
must-see events mainly because you have
no idea when he's gonna stream
next but in september he streamed a ton
focusing on racking up giant combos with
a fake skateboard
thanks to another popular streamer moon
moon
[Music]
moon moon is a pretty popular twitch
streamer regularly pulling in 14
000 viewers while playing whatever game
he wants
he fell over oh
and in early september moon moon decided
to take a bit of a nostalgia trip
see around this time tony hawk's pro
skater 1-2 remastered dropped
and moon moon decided to jump back into
one of his childhood favorites
for like several months we'd all hang
out
at my brother's friend's house we lived
across the street
and we were all playing tony hawk two or
one
i can't remember i'm pretty sure it was
one and then two now make no mistake
about it people didn't know what to
expect when this remaster was announced
would it be like the clunky hd remaster
that came out in 2012
or worse would it be like the absolute
disaster that was tony hawk's pro skater
5 that came out in 2015
but thankfully we got the exact opposite
this version of tony hawk's pro skater
finally feels right it brings back
memories that both moon moon and a lot
of his viewers
hadn't thought about in years
i did it i did it after reliving
memories and playing the game for a few
hours
moon moon jumped into one of the
series's classic levels
hangar oh wait we're about to play the
best level in any tony hawk game
muscle memory quickly had him flying
around the map and messing with tricks
and
soon enough he realized that with enough
practice
he could pull off some sick combos
my potential has yet to be unleashed so
moo moon began his grind to hit a four
million point
combo and the news quickly reached the
ears of his friend clint
who was also playing the game what's the
level that movement is trying to get
maximum points on the hangar
what's his uh is he trying to do max
combo
or is he just trying to get like what's
what's his highest combo what's his high
score he's trying to get 4 million
but before clint could beat him to it
moon moon hit his 4 million combo
after hours and hours and hours of
resets
[Music]
but just because moon moon hit his 4
million combo score doesn't mean
clint lost it just means that the goal
post moved back a little bit
and clint now needed to beat moon moon's
score
which he did after hours and hours of
grinding
yeah that's what i'm talking about and i
beat him too
that's what i'm talking about clint's
4.4 million point combo was a
declaration of war
a war of attrition that saw the stubborn
duo subject their viewers to nothing but
hangar
for days and days on end and from the
outside it looked like clint was the
clear-cut
winner he was the speedrunner after all
used to no life in games
all the time but moon moon yeah
moon moon was ready for battle
21 points
something we have beaten moon to 20
million
i told you guys i would do it
[Music]
for days the two streamers traded scores
out doing each other a little bit on
every run
it was an intense back and forth that
played out in real time
but on the seventh day of their battle
moon moon did something absolutely
incredible
almost triple clint's 21 million on
stream high score
moon moon jumped out to a huge lead a
lead clint had to deal with for a few
days while he prepared to compete in the
fall guys twitch rivals tournament
while also dealing with a broken
controller yeah
he literally broke his controller from
playing too much tony hawk's pro skater
i talked about it with moon moon i
broke my xbox one controller because i
have been squeezing it so hard that the
internals must be warped
and like the whole thing is just
breaking so two days came and went with
moon moon looking more and more like the
victor
but on the 10th day clint returned armed
with a vengeance
and a bunch of new controllers and with
those new controllers clint
ascended to the skateboarding heavens
there we go just a half hour into his
first stream back at it clint reclaimed
the lead
but five hours later he crushed that
score
82 dude let's go
moon moon gave it everything he had but
in the end he gave up
drunk and kind of done with no lifeing a
single level from a 20 year old
franchise for days on end
i can see it's over
i got too much [ __ ] that i want to play
in my stream i
can't go on and after he gave up moon
moon showed the world the glorious video
he had planned if he had won
i had this whole gag prepared and
everything dude check this [ __ ] out
i was gonna have i was gonna drop a
hundred million dude
i was gonna do this [ __ ] right check
this out oh my god i left my zoom open
dude
holy [ __ ] someone's calling me oh hey
what's up clint
uh hey man i just want to say i'm really
sorry to hear that you end up in second
place after trying so
hard i know you're practicing and you
thought you were gonna have it but
maybe next time don't suck so much i
don't know
subscribe to movement on twitch and and
we'll see how you progress
all right good luck after 10 days almost
40 hours of streaming
and a broken controller and clint was
declared the champion
sure he didn't win anything and one of
the game's devs already blew past
both their scores days earlier but clint
lives for these kind of competitions
it's in his speedrunning blood
you know when i stream most of the time
i don't have a goal
and it's hard for me to get into it it's
like well why am i here why would i put
under this earth
and then when i play something like this
it's like
i can just ignore it for a while and
just be like i'm just trying to get a
good score
that's my goal i understand my purpose
now
in fact he's already started a new
competition this time in minecraft
how good are you at minecraft speed
horrible i haven't even made it to the
fortress and i've been playing like four
hours
would you want to do a bet with me and
simply on seeing who can get under an
hour first uh yeah sure i'll do that and
while watching two streamers fail at
skateboard tricks
for hours on end might be mind-numbingly
repetitive
clint and moon moon's tony hawk streams
transported a lot of us
boomers back to the early 2000s and
allowed us to relive
a part of our childhood the question now
is
who's going to revive neopets
you